Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a ton of time
on Bernie's reaction to Kirsten Cinema leaving
the Democratic Party. But I do think it's
important and interesting because Bernie also
is an independent who has made very, very clear I
caucus with the Democrats and there are specific
reasons why Bernie is an independent. Vermont
is also a unique state in terms of its political
orientation and alignment. Vermont Republicans
are different than national Republicans, and gun
ownership is a different thing. In Vermont,
we've talked about sort of the interesting,
different dynamics of Vermont. Bernie
Sanders appeared on CNN to talk about I mean,
he I don't know that he appeared to talk about
Kirsten cinema, but Dana Bash certainly talked
to him about it and he was pretty clear he's
not super impressed with Kirsten. Cinema calls
her a corporate Democrat and says quite a
few accurate but critical things about her.
Let's take a listen to what Bernie had to say.
Speaker 2: You are an independent. She is now
the third official independent of the US Senate
joining you and Angus King of Maine. What do you
think of her decision and also what you just
heard in her interview with Jake? I don't want
to spend a whole lot of time on Senator Cinema.
She has her reasons. Donna I happen to suspect
that it's probably a lot to do with politics back
in Arizona. I think the Democrats there are not
all that enthusiastic about somebody who helped
sabotage some of the most important legislation
that protects the interests of working families.
Speaker 1: And so that's that's a
pretty clear shot across the bow.
Speaker 2: Voting rights and so forth.
So I think it really has to do with her political
aspirations for the future in Arizona. But for us,
I think nothing much has changed in terms of
the functioning of the US Senate. The good news
is that we now have our 51 votes. We'll have a
majority on committees. That means that we can
go forward and start protecting the interests of
the working families and deal with the reality
that we are increasingly living in an oligarchy
where the billionaire class and large corporations
control almost every aspect of our country. So I
would hope very much that with this new majority,
Democrats will sit down and start fighting for
the needs of ordinary Americans. So I want to
talk about some of those issues in a second.
But first, you were a very important figure on
the campaign trail for progressives ahead of the
midterms, as you normally are, I'm sure you're
going to be campaigning for candidates in 2024.
The outgoing Arizona Democratic Party official,
one of them says that he expects Democrats
will run their own candidate against her.
Is that a good idea? Would you support a
Democratic opponent against Senator Cinema?
Speaker 1: Good question.
Speaker 2: I support progressive candidates
all over this country, people who have the guts to
take on powerful special interests. I don't know
what's going to be happening in Arizona. We'll see
who they nominate, but certainly that's something
I will take a hard look at. Does she have the
guts to take on powerful special interests?
No. She now she is a corporate Democrat who
has, in fact, along with Senator Manchin,
sabotaged enormously important legislation.
Speaker 1: So two sides to this, of course.
Number one, to the extent that Kirsten
Sinema will caucus with Democrats and
mostly continue voting with Democrats, even
if she is a centrist corporate Democrat,
as Bernie says, her vote is still useful. And
if 60 votes are needed, at least plausibly,
that's one fewer Republican vote that would
be necessary. Fine. But at the same time,
Bernie is clear about Kirsten cinema's political
views. And as we've seen over the last two years,
there's been a lot of playing coy with her
supposed independence, which is really center
right ism at the end of the day. Bernie's being
very clear while being sort of diplomatic. We
really can't say much more about how the next two
years are going to go without seeing how they go.
It's just guesswork and predicting as the bills
start being voted on. We're very quickly going
to learn much more about it. But good to see that
Bernie isn't confused about what's going on here.